stoicism is a school of philosophy that
developed in ancient Greece during the
so-called helenistic age indeed stoicism
was probably the most widespread and
popular School of philosophy in the
helenic world right up until the rise of
neoplatonism in the third and fourth
centuries but would of course continue
to have an influence even to this very
day it was founded in Athens that most
Central of ancient cities for philosophy
its very name stoicism comes from the
Greek term sto poil which means painted
porch and refers to a literal porch that
stood right next to the agura or
Marketplace in Athens it was here in the
middle of the bustling City Life that
the first stoics would gather to
purposely engage with the public